hello everybody my name is dr. Markham
Blair ph.d doctorate of Fine Arts I
actually went back to real medical to
school school and they've taught me how
to doctor good they actually taught me
how to find motor control and more
appropriateness of the not killing
patients thing whatever that may mean I
have no idea myself but in accordance
with regulation pH 72 xyb I have
officially gotten better as a doctor by
not going to a Nicaraguan doctor school
so we popped in this magical black disc
here with the death and skill of a
master surgeon nigel we've been watching
your performance we require your
services in a special mission by
inserting this desk you have agreed to
come with us
an agent will be longed to be you
immediately imminently we are in space
and yes I actually have been practicing
so I am much better than I was before
Wow look at that view quite amazing I
imagine we're on a Kerbal space ship of
some sort oh that scalpel just stabbed
him in the eyeball anyway let's see what
do we need here to get this done how
about a good old hammer
I've been practicing but I haven't been
practicing in space mind you so where
Boosh key oh boy this is gonna be rough
a little bit difficult here hang on I
got this
hang on lastly let me since it's no
gravity I can actually easily adjust
things here maybe unless it goes off
flying Oh perfect hammering position pop
Boosh or not or not ah or not I am good
doctor I am good doctor doctor you need
to actually swing the hammer shut up
nurse I'm now an official doctor not
from from fake crappy nicaraguan plays I
really I'm having trouble swinging this
I can't swing and swung at the set there
we go swing and swung
yin and yang her juice got to golike up
a bit and then then on the downswing you
rah there we go I'm getting it I'm
getting it got it got it got it so and
then yeah nope
yeah you got to go down on the on the
after you hit the apex of your perfect
Apogee of of ham earnest miss miss miss
miss yeah yeah come on yeah yeah damn it
yeah fudge
oh god I'm losing them aluminium
actually we're doing just fine so stop
panicking stop panicking nurse I know
what's best okay anyway gonna hit him
right in the liver that's good for him
get a shock to his heart from the liver
enzymes the the Borbon CLOB enslave Oh
enzyme it's like a cage here I can't
just get these last bones out there like
perfectly distributed to just block
everything that I need to get out and I
can't frickin head um cuz I'm such an
idiot yeah yeah oh come on man this is
harder than I thought it'd be with the
hammer I mean it probably fine with
everything else is just trying to swing
the hammer at the same time as you're
going down is really difficult there we
go okay just this last one here he's not
losing blood very fast so wonk no not
that one
and did you get it no yeah there we go
got it yeah hey go away hammer I never
need you ever again now let's stop this
meager bit of bleeding here hello
oh there we go it's like that and then
dab it in not myself please what I had
that I had that nervous aren't you
supposed to be I don't know assisting me
but doctor you said I shouldn't get
emotional I know what I said
Oh Pass this is exactly what I didn't
want to happen and it just rocketed off
into I don't know where so hang on let
me try to cure myself
whereas it where is it where is it where
is it where is it actually I can't tell
where it actually is okay hold still and
let me jab myself nurse please inject me
okay it's gone off but hahaha hahaha
that's okay we're okay it's fine it
doesn't want to cooperate that's fine
everything's wrong everything's wrong
all right thanks gone wrong get back
here
I'm try say this is my life this is this
is my life I say that you know I'm gonna
be just fine and I'm gonna take it
common quietly but then my nurse starts
annoying me and I have no scalpels left
where I'm all out of scalpels where the
hell it sucks that I can't say anything
I would love to be able to sneeze or
cotton swabs what good is a cotton swab
I can't see anything
I got nothing everything went up and out
even the heart is at up I just knocked
the heart out so I'm officially boning
what the hell you gotta be joking me
that is such bull has such bull haha you
gotta be kidding me I'm gonna try to set
some things down gently there oh man
that was that was such amazingly
annoying I was incredibly annoying I
mean what the hell
everything went away that's not fair
that was just not fair you guys got to
admit that was not fair
like I've been surprisingly calm here
I've been doing it you know with skill
and perseverance and I don't think this
is gonna work because he's gonna bleed
too quickly hopefully I can get it this
just gently gently on the bones only
okay if we can get him on the bones only
he doesn't bleed out so this is actually
pretty good for the
so just tap them on the bones until they
go away nice and calm let's get this all
in one big chunk here angle it down a
bit more just like that
just like that Master surgeon see this
is what happened doctor I love you
shut up nurse I know I'm the best doctor
around and most handsome business and
the most talented and with the least
patient casualties even though
apparently I just walk out in the middle
of a surgery oh look at that is a thing
of beauty look at that the rib cage is
just floating away in the well you saw I
saw
you're like my nurse you're overly
attached okay no that is that is the
bigger saw okay
do I grasp it firmly or firmly grasp it
to firmly grasp it firmly wait there we
go
please let go everything wants to float
up you guys know that's not how physics
works in zero gravity things don't
automatically just float up to the sky
come on Dungy
like my watch magically just floating up
to the sky see if I if I go down and
that is eventually gonna bounce out that
table well that's conservation of energy
but so that's fine okay
now I just need a scalpel I just need a
scalpel that is not going to rock it off
into space actually this one right here
I guess that one oh it's just out of my
reach ah you want to tickle oh you stop
the tickle anyone it would your big boy
oh yeah good boy boy dick Abajo that
heart is getting dangerously close to
floating out of my reach if it's not
already if it is oh wow
barely can I get this to stay in here
that would be lovely
please just get nestled in right there
oh no it's floating up oh no oh no oh no
just
just stay down there okay good whoa
Alice that was scary
that was scary man come on firmly grasp
it firmly grasp it we're working where
to go it vanished I see one down there
what what the hell happened to it it
just Oh piss I just injected myself with
oh not them no nothing
super come on come on ere we go firmly
grasp it all right let's get this
stomach out of there
what Chuck ha actually I need to
readjust in Justin well the wind is
gusting gusting dr. Brenda gotcha gotcha
ha booty there we go that's better okay
now we can get it in there angularly and
slice off that that is sliced slice the
arteries of the heart which does not
cause Pro fuses pro pro pro foosh Pro
futile it to bleed profusely is what I'm
trying to say there there we go
heart is out I don't think I need to
actually I'm pretty sure I could just
always my heart of my other heart still
there it's not where to go where to go
where my other heart go no no you scared
me oh my god oh that was like oh okay
nothing bump into the other heart please
I just want to grab it very gently and
firmly grasp it firmly grasp it and
nestle it oh no you're gonna be like
that really ha ha really esophagus just
come on cooperate with me get out of the
heart area
that's in there right that's that looks
good enough let me try to get this
I think this other cord is the stomach
cord thingy is blocking my oh come no no
way
now V gah doctor I think you just need
to crowd the cooks out nurse I know it
best it's stuck underneath one of the
other Oh No
get out of there there we go okay ha ha
let go let go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is my life this is my life it was
that close I was that close that close
the stomach lining gets out there I
finally get the stomach lining it won't
let go off my fingers as I'm desperately
trying to grab the heart as I push it
away let's put a log in there get
something in there tickle tickle tickle
no it's not working
Bob no can I get this cash back off you
Bob got your nose what is that please
tell me that's that looks like a live
heart again use the lung you're used to
ribs to scoop it out no way no way
that's impossible it's impossible oh my
god give me the ribs
give me the ribs get out of the way you
stupid lid oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
my just oh oh gently gently gently push
push gently
[Music]
no no no no